[Musica]
lo sapevate che in cima alla lista di
google france
uno degli argomenti più cliccati è
autumn significa che c'è sete di
conoscenza che le persone vogliono
sapere come si fa a fare qualcosa
insomma vogliono entrare nel backstage
ed ecco quello che farò io quest oggi
cercherò di portarvi un po nel dietro le
quinte del mio mondo
il mondo della musica classica della
direzione d'orchestra delle dinamiche
nella vita perche strà per me questo
mondo è una passione ma non solo è
quella cosa che mi spinge a migliorarmi
ogni giorno ea focalizzarmi suoi
messaggi che che voglio trasmettere è un
mondo complesso a volte complicato ma
sicuramente entusiasmante dal mondo
fatto di studio di preparazione di
sacrificio di prove di relazioni umane
di adrenalina e di sintonia una sintonia
che necessario creare per raggiungere la
magia del concerto e allora cominciamo
vi siete mai chiesti che cosa fa un
direttore d'orchestra con tutti questi
movimenti
sale di un pool b ecco sgombra subito il
campo non si tratta di incantesimi
lanciati dalla nostra bacchetta che
magica purtroppo non è né di una strana
danza propiziatoria
per quanto ci sia da chi sul web
effettivamente si è divertito con gli
spurs di harry potter
tuttavia qualcosa di attinenti alla
magia c'è ma ci arriverà più tardi
dunque che cosa deve fare un direttore
sicuramente deve tenere il tempo non
mostrare l'andamento ma insomma se fosse
solo per questo basterebbe appunto
metronomo oppure come accade in certi
brani di alcuni repertori specifici come
quello dell'epoca barocca delle poche
classica questa funzione in grado di
assolvere la anche il primo violino
perché dovete sapere che la figura del
direttore d'orchestra così come la
intendiamo oggi in realtà è la figura
piuttosto recente
se torniamo dietro al settecento
troviamo appunto un membro
dell'orchestra che a guidare gli altri
musicisti generalmente appunto il primo
violino se torniamo ancora più indietro
nel tempo al seicento troviamo il bacio
c'è una persona che se ne stava sul
palcoscenico al lato di palcoscenico
abbattere il tempo con un bastone
metallico pesantissimo sul pavimento
ligneo del palco appunto e con questo
teneva il tempo per l'orchestra perché
poteva essere credetemi anche un
mestiere piuttosto pericoloso come ci
dimostra la vicenda di john battisti
villini c'è un matisse titoli che nel
1687 si trovava alla corte del re sole
approvare il suo te deum ed era talmente
preso talmente concentrato su queste
prove che a forza di battere il tempo
fini con infilzarsi proprio il piede
piede che andò in cancrena cancrena che
si è stesa la gamba gamba che non vuole
farsi amputare e beh il resto della
storia le lascio immaginare dunque
diciamo al tempo poi le dinamiche quindi
dobbiamo mostrare si sono
pianoforte ma anche questo in definitiva
già scritto sulle parti dei musicisti
vedere dobbiamo partire dal presupposto
che ognuno dei 50 70 100 o anche più
musicisti che un direttore trova in
orchestra davanti a sè nel momento in
cui sale sul podio ecco ognuno di loro è
un musicista preparatissimo diplomato
assolutamente in grado di interpretare
ciò che si trova scritto nella musica
davanti a sé interpretare ecco del
problema perché potremmo potenzialmente
ritrovarci ad avere 50 70 100 o più
versioni interpretazioni
contemporaneamente nello stesso brano ed
è qui che interviene il direttore
d'orchestra mio primo maestro piero
bellugi una volta mi disse che il
compito del direttore d'orchestra è
quello di unificare le coscienze
musicale per carità nient'altro e quindi
il fine è quello di creare un'unica ed
unitaria interpretazione di una
composizione dunque il direttore deve
allineare ad una visione comune una
visione talmente forte che non può che
essere condivisa e come vedete parla di
condivisione ecco la condivisione ci
approcciamo al tema della leadership che
per me è una leadership oggi in più
partecipativa rispetto al passato
quindi non più la figura del direttore
dittatore che del resto risulta superata
anche rispetto al momento storico e
culturale che stiamo vivendo ma un
qualcuno che miri a valorizzare a far
crescere il singolo che mi riconosca i
risultati vedete questo ovviamente
dipende da ciò che si decide è molto
soggettivo ciò che si decide di attuare
come tipologie di leadership e mi rendo
conto anche che alle volte
sia necessario per quanto io credo
fortemente del team building se
necessario adottare quello che mi
definisco che mi piace definire effetto
tacere che per me significa passare
all'incirca da questo a questo perché
poi sapete durante un live può succedere
veramente di tutto
e ognuno reagisce come può questa carlos
player durante una recita di rose che
variano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
come vedete questo era un live davvero
non era una prova d'orchestra dunque il
direttore si mette al centro e se mette
al centro perché deve essere il pilastro
forte e stabile su cui tutti gli artisti
quindi non soltanto l'orchestra
credetemi perché se si tratta di opera
abbiamo anche i cantanti coro alle
maestranze dietro dietro le quinte e su
cui tutti sentono di poter contare ad
essere colui o colei che a pelle e non a
parole trasmette il messaggio che
qualsiasi cosa succeda a quelli di
studio knight come diceva un altro mio
maestro e per farci aprire temi siano a
dir tanto tre minuti dal momento esatto
in poi si sale su quel metro quadrato
che il podio mettete le orchestre sono
degli organismi complessi e spietati che
immediatamente annusano chi hanno
davanti decidono immediatamente si è
semplicemente sì o no
specialmente nelle orchestre più
blasonate accade il direttore
specialmente se giovane se non è ancora
un grande nome debba essere accettato
e a questo punto quando parlo di queste
cose generalmente c'è sempre un
misunderstanding perché si tende a
credere che ci sia un lungo periodo di
conoscenza tra il direttore e
l'orchestra e questo è vero nella misura
in cui si tratti di un direttore stabile
o di un direttore principale
dell'orchestra quindi c'è una relazione
un rapporto più continuativo ma spesso e
volentieri noi direttore ci troviamo ad
essere dei direttori ospiti
dunque mentre l'orchestra gli
orchestrali tra di loro si conoscono
benissimo perché sono abituati a
lavorare insieme e si comportano quasi
come un unico organismo in simbiosi
proprio ecco al contrario con un
direttore ospite hanno appena 23 giorni
riprova che noi ma di arrivare al
concerto
ma torniamo indietro dicevamo appunto
che il direttore si mette al centro ma
allo stesso tempo deve essere anche in
grado di delegare mi faccio subito un
esempio io nasco come pianista dunque
posso suggerire ai violini o ai flauti a
qualsiasi altro strumento la tipologia
di suono che voglio ottenere magari
insomma il risultato l'effetto però
lascerò a loro la risoluzione tecnica il
problema perché riconosco loro la
competenza tecnica per farlo anch'io
sarà in grado di fornire la risoluzione
tecnica di la soluzione appunto perché
un direttore per quanto non debba
necessariamente saper suonare tutti gli
strumenti né deve comunque conoscere le
peculiarità quindi la la tecnica la
prassi esecutiva però deciso di delegare
appunto per rispetto dei ruoli per
valorizzare il sindaco il singolo
appunto e quindi appunto è molto questa
è una questione che mi sta molto a cuore
credo che sia molto importante questo io
interverrò soltanto nel momento in cui
vedrò il problema non viene risolto come
la mia aspettativa
un altro esempio sul rispetto dei ruoli
l'orchestra è divisa in sezioni e
strumenti ad arco strumenti a fiato che
a loro volta si distinguono in legni e
ottoni strumenti a percussione la
persona più importante che troviamo in
orchestra dopo il direttore d'orchestra
è il primo violino quello che siede alla
sinistra del direttore e tale importanza
di viene riconosciuto dall'appellativo
di spalla su cui piangere a lucca ansa
e sotto di lui troviamo gerarchicamente
appunto tutte le prime parti delle altre
sezioni dunque ogni mia richiesta per
quella sezione specifica passerà
attraverso la prima parte di quella
sezione questo perché appunto c'è una
gerarchia una
appunto una gerarchia che è importante
rispettare ed ecco perché il perché
della magia di cui parlavo all'inizio
perché un direttore deve fare tutto
questo in un arco di tempo molto
risicato come dicevamo prima all'incirca
queste due tre prove e poi concerto deve
farlo parlando il meno possibile
mostrando con i gesti ma soprattutto
passando attraverso tutto quello che non
è soltanto linguaggio paraverbale e non
verbale ma eppure qualcosa in più e ciò
che si definisce appello o scambio di
energia insomma un qualcosa di non
descrivibile secondo le categorie entro
cui siamo abituati a ragionare
è un po come se aveste la possibilità di
trasmettere i concetti che dovete
passare quotidianamente i vostri
colleghi quasi esclusivamente attraverso
sguardi mimica facciale gesti magari un
pizzico di telepatia
sapete cosa diceva leonard bernstein
bernstein diceva la tecnica e
comunicazione
queste due parole sono sinonimi nel
direttore d'orchestra comunicazione ecco
la parola chiave una delle orchestre che
io oggi dirigo come direttore principale
el orchestra scarlatti young di napoli
composta circa 30 elementi
i miei musicisti sono proprio gli anche
perché hanno tra 18 e 28 anni e leggo la
loro passione la passione per la musica
classica nei loro occhi non dobbiamo
fare l'errore di pensare che la musica
classica sia un qualche cosa di distante
antiquato
al contrario al suo interno a un vero e
proprio potenziale capace di stupire e
coinvolgere le nuove generazioni
ecco questo il mio messaggio per voi
quest'oggi la musica classica per
parafrasare il titolo di un noto film
non è una cosa per vecchi e più in
generale la musica tutta in tutti i suoi
generi la musica
la musica e formazione la musica e
comunicazione
la musica e amore e con questo voglio
arrivare al punto focale della mia
visione dell'innovazione non si innesca
il meccanismo dell'innovazione né si può
essere autenticamente innovativi
se non si è consapevoli della propria
origine e tradizione per me oggi è
innovativo riconoscere che per quanto
poi si esplicano con modalità diverse
sicuramente con un livello di
artisticità che indubbiamente diversa in
realtà l'opera lirica il hip hop ad
esempio nascono dalla stessa necessità
espressiva di raccontare la
contemporaneità e la contingenza
attraverso l'uso tra l'altro di figure
retoriche specialmente l'allegoria e
soprattutto attraverso l'ironia
ecco io credo che serva un cambio di
mentalità servono figure nuove figure
che ci dimostrino la modernità della
tradizione figure che vogliano e che
siano in grado di comunicare con il
pubblico e con i media
figure che combattano ai pregiudizi
dall'esterno e dall'interno del mondo
accademico
vedete per la mia giovane età e per il
fatto di essere una donna
spesso mi sono ritrovata a dover
combattere pregiudizi e alcuni addetti
ai lavori specialmente quelli di
generazioni più grandi che sono dunque
tendenzialmente più restii al
cambiamento
e allora mi chiedo come si fa a
convincere al cambiamento
come si fa a renderlo vero e vivo io
credo attraverso l'esempio diretto
poiché il processo primario di
apprendimento quello con cui impariamo
da bambini è proprio limitazione abbiamo
una storia abbiamo una tradizione
importante e sono convinta che oggi più
che mai sia necessario rinnovarla quella
questa tradizione
il che non significa distruggerla o
stravolgerla snaturarla anzi e significa
prendere il meglio e valorizzarlo del
resto come faccio ad infrangere le
regole se non conosco le regole del
gioco e per chiamare in causa massimi
temi come faccio a sapere dove andare se
non so da dove provengo grazie a sky ci
riesce
[Applauso]